bon puisque à vous taper des pieds je
vais vous la lie ce moment je suis bien
arrivé à la guerre war on a tiré les
rois c'est moi qui l' affaire elle
mesurait 10 cm de long et elle a pénétré
très profondément dans mon bras gauche
après l'opération j'ai bu du champagne
ça pique j'ai cassé ma montre là ma mère
aveugle et il me reste plus que la
petite bulle ça ne me gêne pas trop mais
je redoute que quelqu'un me demande
l'heure on est passé par amsterdam
non le port ya des marins qui chante et
qui pisse relativement fort de
préférence sur des fans masculins
parlez-en vite à monsieur le curé mais
ne lui dites surtout pas que c'est moi
qui est captée puis c'est le moment que
ici je trouve plein de champignons comme
je suis souvent à plat ventre je les
vois plus facilement mais il va falloir
que j'arrête de gratter la terre avec
mon fusil sa bouche le canon il n'est
pas méchant le capitaine mais il crie
très fort
l'autre jour il s'est vraiment fâché
très très fort je suis allé directement
de prison je ne suis pas passé par la
case départ je n'ai même pas reçu vingt
mille j'ai eu c'est moi de cachot c'est
loin de cachot ça paraît long mais j'ai
trouvé une combine en dormant 12 à 13
heures par jour je les portais trois
mois effectifs au pour noël mon copain a
eu des biscuits moi j'ai eu une
bronchite
on m'a volé mes chaussures que j'avais
laissé aux traits d'un sapin ici on ne
peut faire confiance à personne
on est très mal entouré en fait on est
complètement encerclées dit à mon frère
il arrête de m'envoyer des paquets et
décoller
au début je trouvais ça drôle
à présent mes nerfs lâchent un petit peu
le général vient de nous annoncer que
nous serions tous rapidement
l'exterminer ne regardez le mot
exterminés dans le dictionnaire et mende
mais assez efficace ion exact répond moi
le plus vite possible
à propos des factures de gaz
d'électricité que tu trouves tu cher je
te signale que le montant à payer est
inscrit dans une case à droite de la
quittance depuis trois ans tu payes la
date
c'est pour ça que ça a tendance à
augmenter tous les jours signé ton petit
euro vi t'aime très fort